we have a collective interest in not
um
liquidating the well-being introduced to
the landscape by beavers we have a
collective interest and a lineage level
interest right right our descendants
five generations from now depend on the
fact that we will not have ignored the
equilibrium factor and just depleted at
the highest rate possible and then
assumed that some process would
magically rescue us at the end of that
yep right those processes sometimes do
rescue us and sometimes they don't and
we can't afford the ones that don't
um but but anyway the point is and this
is one of these really important places
where there is a discussion that
absolutely has to take place between
um what I would call a hard-headed
progressives and I don't want to presume
to Define you but I believe you are a
hard-headed progressivism I
and so-called conservatives and what I
hope will happen is that the
conservatives of whom
there are many who are frankly
struggling to preserve the gains that 10
years ago we all agreed were good right
struggling to preserve you know a fair
colorblind Society
um in which everyone has access to the
market and you know a means to get ahead
in which you know Merit produces Rewards
conservatives who are doing that job
are
I now find them
strangely deaf to the idea that being a
conservative also naturally requires us
to preserve the substrate on which we
all live right that the society that
does you know reward hard work and
insight and doesn't give a damn what
color your skin is or what your sexual
orientation is or any of those other
parameters that Society
only works if the underlying stuff
continues to exist for us to to utilize
and in some sense what I'm getting at is
I believe that sustainability is a
natural concept that conservatives
should embrace but because of
uh
the dialogue about ecology having
focused so heavily on global warming and
because there are clearly things wrong
with the portrayal of global warming I
don't know I assume you're not a dark
horse uh listener but
you know Heather and I have navigated
this a bunch of times right we are
believe that global warming is real but
we also believe that we are being given
a story that's far too
um
black and white to be realistic that it
does have a high PR budget yeah it has a
very high PR budget and my conservative
neighbors would point out gives them a
certain amount of skepticism it is a
very good reason for skepticism and the
fact that we know from inside the
academy that any time people are in a
panic over some process that is
threatening them the chances that the
literature represents an accurate
exploration of the factors that go in
One Direction or the other is
effectively zero right so you know I
think the point is
the models a models are not the same
thing as empirical results and we are
treating those models as empirical
results
and those models models are always
suspect because you can if you are
willing to put enough parameters into a
model you can get it to match any
Behavior you want it doesn't mean that
you've identified something real right
it becomes just a self-fulfilling uh
generator of academic papers but so if
we put aside that we know that there's
something wrong with the discussion
about global warming and that that's
dangerous and tragic because we do need
to know what the truth of it is right
but just put aside global warming the
point is we've got an environmental
crisis that has nothing to do with
global warming global warming we're a
complete fiction we would still be in a
very dangerous circumstance because of
Collective action questions in Game
Theory because of failure to recognize
equilibria and you know those things
require good governance to solve them
and this is you know this is the bitter
pill I think for uh libertarianism right
I have some sympathy with Libertarians
because I believe they have identified
the central value that we should be
maximizing right realized Liberty is a
great value to maximize precisely
because it forces you to solve every
other issue right you know you can't you
can't be free if you are in danger of
being wiped out by a medical crisis in
your family right so if we really tried
to maximize how much Liberty individuals
could act could uh could actually
exercise then we would have to solve all
of these problems and good governance is
required of course at the moment
I don't think anybody who's looking at
what our governments are doing can be
all that enthusiastic about empowering
them right so anyway I've again led us
for our field but
um well I think there's an interesting
thing here and that
um
if we focus on carbon
it's kind of hard to wrap your mind
around especially when it's in the air
it's invisible yep you know non-toxic
can't see it doesn't smell maybe uh
maybe something technological will save
us yep right but until then there's not
much anybody can do uh with the typical
tool kit yep whereas if you're thinking
about the water cycle and you're
thinking about
this complex system
there's a lot that each individual human
can do
to facilitate a shift I mean it becomes
a land use conversation right and
um
you know it's interesting what I have a
lot of friends who are are very
conservative and they uh
they have a
um a deeper relation to the land if I'm
gonna paint with a broad brush that a
lot of my friends who are much more
Progressive right in fact usually the
folks who know the most about Beaver are
the beaver Trappers that are being
demonized then by the folks who are
trying to save the beaver right and yet
these uh these folks know more about
beavers than a lot of the folks who are
raising money for Beaver projects right
um
but I wonder if there's something with
the Baseline you know the Baseline that
conservatives are are feeling protective
of
um doesn't extend far enough back
to prior to when we started
the extractive process that is
um
you know not going to go too long in the
future like like there's something
that's invisible back there when beavers
were in charge of water
for all of North America
and and
we the conservation tendency the current
conservative tendency to like hey let's
stabilize this system where it's at and
just change when we see it necessary
um I don't think it's it sees that I
mean this was the case when we came in
and uh made national parks right the
Yosemite is the perfect example where
there's these huge beautiful Meadows and
these you know towering trees and and
there was the conservatives at the time
were like there's just this one problem
there's these people who live here right
you know and I I encountered this with
some of the work I did with you and
Heather when we were in Panama too like
this tendency to be like well let's just
get the people out and then this
beautiful thing will be retained all
right the awanichi yeah the Indians who
were yeah we're happier now what does
that Valley look like well is it fully
encroached in Brush you know all those
flowers that were the first foods that
people were maintaining are diminished
and you realize that was another because
ecosystem the engineer that we took off
the landscape people were in charge of
Justice beavers have been methodically
managing
the waterways right people were
methodically managing the Uplands with
fire so so we see these collapses right
but but the conservation tendency
was blind to the process applying to the
people who are maintaining a productive
system with fire or that beavers were
maintaining a productive system with
water
so I don't know I agree with your
diagnosis there's a you know there's a
willingness to look back a certain
distance but not far enough to really
understand that you know you have
stepped into a new realm and you're
you're failing to you know whether
you're a conservative or a progressive
or whatever you are you're failing to
preserve this thing of value and
my sense is that people are basically
alike in that they
appreciate
um
beautiful places they appreciate uh
things that don't require intensive work
to maintain right give people the
opportunity and everybody looks you know
at a gorgeous landscape and has
a positive feeling about it all right
right
um what
what I don't what I don't know what to
do about is
we start doing something
at a small scale inherently that's how
everything starts and when you are at
that small scale the fact that that
process if you were to extrapolate up to
some you know
immense inflation of that same process
then becomes a threat to your very
ability to persist
at what point does it make sense to have
that conversation right does it make
sense to have that conversation when
you're experimenting you know on the
workbench in your garage with that
little process that if it really caught
on a hundred years later would be an
issue no right you should be allowed to
experiment but the
there is no way that functioning at the
scale that we are at that the right
answer to the question doesn't involve
okay
in what way can we rationally rain
ourselves in without triggering any of
the failure modes right well if we rain
ourselves in and our competitors Don't
Rain themselves in the place gets
destroyed anyway and we will also have
lost out and they will be more powerful
than we classic tragedy of the commons
that's a problem you have to solve right
you you cannot do this as a matter of
personal responsibility you cannot do
this with your nation behaving
responsibly and others not behaving
responsibly it has to be done as a
matter of some kind of good governance
and I don't know how you would do it at
the moment I'm absolutely terrified of
government's having more power because I
think they're all malignant I don't know
of a government that I trust at the
moment but you know I also don't want to
die of that concern because it means
well we're not going to manage any of
the things that have to be managed in
order for us to persist so doesn't that
seem like a natural place where
conservatives and progressives
ought to be talking at this moment about
how can we keep doing you know how can
we continue to have the goose that lays
the golden eggs without destroying the
world on which it lives
yeah and and what I found doing the work
that I do is it
it is uniting
for folks like as long as it can not
become a fuzzy animal that needs saved
issue
we can stick to
Beaver are a process this is intelligent
complex thing that we need to defer to
we need to put the professionals back in
charge of our water
because what we've been doing with the
water doesn't seem to be working very
well right
um that's something that I found
consistently everyone can get on board
with but then you start saying well
on your land
you now have to make a concession you
have to take those three acres out of
productivity and allow beavers to return
it to Wetland and that's where things
get edgy because people are making
livelihoods off this land right and it's
like why would I incur the cost to
society Society values a system that's
working better and Society values Beaver
but
and then I am as a landowner going to
incur the cost of that you know what's
in it for me
[Music]